this video is sponsored by the book
summary and Discovery app blinkist use
the link in the description and receive
40 off blinkus premium
you're a construction worker you're
working a job with a crew of six
building a small railroad station you've
been on the job for several days by the
end of the day today you'll be done
you're excited to go home and enjoy a
couple days off with your friends and
family
everything is going normally beginning
to wrap up when suddenly you hear a loud
crack a pillar on the front of the
station is broken causing the station's
roof to collapse sideways pulling the
rest of the building's infrastructure
out in towards you you try to get out of
the way but you can't you and four
co-workers become pinned on the train
tracks by the debris you can't barely
move you try to maintain your composure
with the feeling of panic begins to set
in quickly exasperated by the bellowing
yells of your co-workers some of them
are injured
you become confused when suddenly their
yells go quiet there's a vibrational hum
in the distance that replaces them then
a train horn
the yells pick back up now change from
the sound of pain to the sound of Terror
closer and closer you hear and feel the
train come this is it you think to
yourself
you hear one of your co-workers yelling
switch the track switch the track
you remember there's a man control booth
on the bridge about 40 yards behind you
inside the attendant can push a button
that will switch the tracks and divert
the train away right before it hits you
join in on the now Collective chant to
change the tracks
after a moment passes you hear someone
else yelling near you but not with you
it's your other co-worker and good
friend he is pinned on the other track
the person in the control Booth sees
what's happening they saw the whole
thing and called for help immediately
but it won't get here in time they watch
the oncoming train get closer and closer
they have a decision to make choose to
switch the track and have the train kill
one person or do nothing and let the
Train Kill a total of five people
you feel the vibration of the train
increase as you consider your whole life
a tapestry of experiences and feelings
relationships and achievements desires
and hopes
you plead for it to continue you don't
want to die
no one here does
the person in the booth is thinking
intensely about what to do they have
about five seconds to decide five four
three two one
this dilemma is a version of the thought
experiment known as the trolley problem
originally posed by philosopher Philippa
Foote in 1967 and later advanced in 1976
by Judith Jarvis Thompson the trolley
problem has become an increasingly
popular and sometimes comical category
of thought experiments that challenge
our most basic moral intuitions and show
us how unclear questions about ethics
and decision-making can easily become to
explore this further imagine for a
moment now that you are the one in the
control booth what would you do would
you do nothing avoiding involving
yourself but allowing five people to die
that you could have otherwise easily
saved or would you switch the tracks and
in some sense cause one person to die
but save the other five
for most people the choice is clear
enough in a variety of different surveys
about 90 percent of respondents claim
that in this situation they would flip
the switch and divert the train after
all five people dying is worse than one
and most people want to do the least
worst thing
this way of thinking follows from one of
the most influential and commonly held
ethical theories known as utilitarianism
originally developed in the 18th century
which describes decisions and actions as
moral when their outcomes result in the
greatest amount of good pleasure
happiness or well-being and the minimal
amount of bad pain or suffering
alternatively however people who
disagree with this Choice might follow
the ethical Theory known as deontology
which argues that decisions and actions
are moral solely based on whether or not
they followed defined rules and
principles and not based on their
consequences in other words for example
the act of killing someone under any
circumstances even if by not killing
them you are essentially killing more
people is and will always be wrong on
principle and therefore since flipping
the switch involves you committing the
act of killing someone doing so is
morally wrong
however this raises the following
question what is the difference between
allowing and causing is there any
by simply observing the event
understanding it and possessing the
ability to easily change and improve it
are you not already involved is there a
difference in involvement between
observation and inaction versus
observation and action isn't choosing to
not be involved a choice that is already
involved no one can choose to not choose
and no one can opt out of what they are
already a part of
what if there was no one on the other
track wouldn't allowing the five people
to die clearly be the wrong thing to do
even at this level in just the original
basic version clearly it isn't 100
obvious what is right and how we ought
to treat the situation and it only gets
far less obvious with subtle changes
what if we change the numbers what if
there are 50 people on the main track
and 10 on the other
how about five thousand on the main
track and one thousand on the other
now if you switch the tracks you will
direct the death of 1 000 people but you
will also save five thousand the
proportions are exactly the same as the
original and therefore the logic should
also be the same but it seems to feel a
lot different knowing that you will at
least be partly responsible for the
death of 1 000 people
what if we change the proportions now on
the main track there are five people on
the other there are two
how about three on the other or four
again from a purely utilitarian and
seemingly rational perspective four is
still less bad than five and so
switching the tracks is still seemingly
the right choice
but yet there almost seems to be a point
at which the difference in people
between the tracks feels more negligible
than the intervention itself is saving
one more person worth the weight of
responsibility you will feel in that
decision what about your own personal
suffering and Trauma as a result of this
how do we weigh that against the Delta
of one person's life
now let's make it even harder what if
there are five people on the main track
and only one on the other
but the one is someone you love a family
member a partner a friend a child what
do you do then
your impulse is most likely not to
switch the tracks that is of course very
understandable but is it right if in the
original version you believe you should
switch the tracks the only difference
here is your emotional attachment to the
one person but the morality and logic of
the situation does not change otherwise
even if in the original version you
believe you should not switch the tracks
just put your loved one in the group of
five on the main track and consider the
same problem
it's your emotional involvement enough
to compromise your morality presumably
the majority of people would say yes and
do the same but then we would have to
also agree that morality is flexible
based on our emotions and not based on
our consistency of logic
how much of Ethics is really just
emotion anyway the meta-ethical theory
known as emotivism argues that ethical
statements never express truths or
falsehoods but rather merely our
emotional states influenced by things
like our cultural and experiential
backgrounds moods personalities and so
on
if this is true how does that affect
things in general
let's return to the bridge in the
original example again five people are
stuck on the train tracks and a small
train is coming
this time however there is no control
Booth button switch or any second track
at all you are just a random pedestrian
watching the event unfold from the
bridge near you however at the edge of
the bridge stands a large man also
observing the event unfold he is massive
morbidly obese you don't know any of the
people on the track you don't know the
obese man but you do know that if you
push the man off the bridge in front of
the train he will cause the train to
stop in time killing him but saving the
other five people
do you do it
in the same surveys mentioned earlier
where ninety percent of respondents
claimed that they would switch the track
by lever or button less than 10 percent
claim that they would push the man off
the bridge but yet it's the same outcome
same number of people same relationship
with the people involved and so on
everything else is exactly the same
neither the man on the alternative track
in the original scenario nor the man on
the bridge in this scenario chose to be
in the situation this obese man is no
more or less involved in the unfolding
of events and they would both be just as
safe if you weren't there
but yet you likely feel differently in
this situation simply because it feels
more personal emotionally you are
affected enough to not do what you
already likely agreed was logical and
moral
for one last twist let's imagine a
different person is in the same
situation on the bridge making the
decision of whether or not to push the
man this person however is psychopathic
and they choose to do whatever you chose
to do but they do it because they want
to feel personally involved in killing
someone or they want to see more people
die in either case does their intention
change the morality of the situation
would they be more or less moral than
someone who chooses to do the opposite
if the psychopath's actions result in
the same outcome of what you believe is
most moral
taking the utilitarian view the
psychopathic person would have done the
more moral thing but who would you want
to be alone in a room with
let's say that they did do the more
moral thing but they are an immoral
person justifiably worth condemning
but what happens if six weeks later they
go to a neurologist after having
experienced months of chronic headaches
and it has discovered that they have a
tumor in their brain that has caused
brain lesions in areas responsible for
Morality and value-based decision-making
the tumor has directly caused their
behavior and decision making to change
in ways that they had no control over
how do we perceive them now are they
morally responsible for their behavior
what if the same person didn't have a
tumor but was horribly abused
psychologically and physically as a
child which directly caused a response
that led to this Behavior
they would not have chosen or controlled
this any more than a tumor is there a
difference
is anyone truly morally responsible for
who they become and the choices they are
led to make if they are by causes they
never chose or controlled to begin with
of course the individual still needs to
be dealt with and taken out of society
rehabilitated if possible but just
because you can't take the tumor out
does not make the person any less of a
victim
ultimately the trolley problems aren't
just interesting thought experiments and
Goofy memes they show us that what we
think is right or wrong is often based
on a lot more than just rational
evaluations of pros and cons good and
bad they reveal to us that decisions and
actions are often a consequence of a
complex array of intentions and beliefs
all puppeteered by a backstory of cause
and effect and a chaotic system
comprised of incalculable variables
the point of these questions isn't to
trick the mind but to demonstrate just
how complicated and unclear matters of
ethical decision making sometimes are
and can be
right now in this moment of History we
are entering new Realms of moral
understanding and new conditions of
societal reality what rights might we
owe our animal cousins how should we
program AI self-driving vehicles and
other Technologies to make decisions on
their own about things like for example
whether or not a self-driving car should
hit one person in order to avoid five
how should we choose when all choices
are bad how will we
how should we update laws and Justice
systems and punishments as we venture
out further into these new Realms of
understanding and Society
in the words of Peter Singer what one
generation finds ridiculous the next
accepts and the third shudders when it
looks back on what the first did
it is both the Wonder and an incredible
feat that we have come as far as we have
as a society and as a species to
understand and agree at scale what it
means to at least try to be moral and to
do our very best every day to behave
accordingly to uphold peace and Order
and reason and understanding
of course there's so much chaos disdain
and misalignment in the world our
immorality is always lurking in each
moment in each stage of history but
there's also so much compassion so much
kindness and desire to treat other
people and things right as best we can
we have come so far we must not forget
this
but we have so much farther still to go
we must not forget this either
this video was sponsored by blinkist
a much easier trolley problem is the
following you're on a train going down a
track you can either do nothing and
everything stays the same or you can
push a button and divert the train onto
a second track that quickly leads to a
ton of new exciting and useful
perspectives and understandings this
button of course is real and you can
push it by clicking the link to blinkist
in the description blinkist is an app
that helps you significantly develop
accelerate and enhance your reading and
learning by condensing over 5 500 of the
best non-fiction books and podcasts
across 27 different categories into
around 15-minute explainers that can be
both read or listened to even while
offline no matter who you are and what
track you want to go down this New Year
blankests tailored content and exclusive
personality driven experiences ensure
that the track you go down gets you to
exactly where you want to go if you want
to be a better critical thinker blinkus
has a great curated collection called
critical thinking skills in seven days
which will teach you how to better
evaluate information deal with external
and internal deceptions and ultimately
make better decisions in particular the
Five Elements of Effective Thinking by
Edward B Berger and Michael starboard is
a great title to learn and develop key
strategies toward improving your
thinking process and enacting positive
changes both in your life and in
particular fields of Interest
and now through blinkus connect premium
users can also share their account with
one other person at no additional cost
enjoy two memberships for the price of
one a seven day free trial and forty
percent off blinkus premium by clicking
the link in the description or by
scanning the QR code on the screen forty
percent off is only valid until the end
of February
and of course as always thank you so
much for watching in general and see you
next video